Hi everyone. My name is Rishi Desai.
I'm an ML engineer at Abundant AI, where
we build reinforcement learning
environments for Frontier Labs.
Today, I'm going to talk about SWE
Marathon, a benchmark that answers a
question that is starting to matter a
lot more.
Can coding agents stay coherent over a
billion token budget?
Can they build Slack from scratch?
Can they rewrite an entire JAX code base
in PyTorch?
Can they build a C compiler in Rust?
This is what SWE Marathon is trying to
measure. What happens when coding agents
move from fixing bugs to owning entire
projects end to end?
There's been a tremendous amount of
interest in autonomous agent systems.
Anthropic has explored teams of agents
building a C compiler.
Cloudflare rebuilt the entire Next.js on
Vite, completely hands-off with agents.
And Cursor has experimented with their
days-long
running autonomous agent harness.
The pattern is that coding agents are
being pointed at whole projects, not
just GitHub issues or linear tickets.
My question is, can we turn some of
these Frontier Labs style case studies
into reproducible eval tasks?
Let's talk about the SWE benchmark
lineage.
Human Eval asked whether models could
write individual Python functions.
SWE-bench was a big jump to real GitHub
issues, where agents had to inspect a
repository, make a patch, and patch some
unit tests.
Terminal-bench pushed this even further
by making each task a full environment
with a verifier. So, agents could use a
terminal, run bash commands,
inspect files, and leave behind a final
container state.
SWE Marathon takes that environment plus
verifier framing and stretches the
horizon to project scale work.
Multi-hour trajectories and coordinated
changes across many, many components.
These are literally hundreds of hours of
human work compressed into a single
agent rollout.
But, once you make tasks this long, a
big problem shows up.
Verification.
In a short benchmark, a weak test
could just be considered as noise.
But,
in a multi-hour environment, a weak
verifier becomes an attack surface.
The agent has hours, a file system,
unrestricted network access potentially,
and a reward signal. So, it could spend
hours probing the verifier instead of
actually doing the intended engineering
work.
That's a big reason why SWE Marathon
uses multiple independent checks.
We have hidden tests,
reference parity checks,
computer use agent checks for the
product clone tasks, and anti-cheating
tests.
We wanted independent verified channels
that fail in different ways.
I'll first show you the computer use
agent verification example, and then
later the failure case
where
an agent tries to solve the C compiler
task by secretly calling GCC.
You You have noticed that there are
basically no full stack product clone
tasks in any long horizon three
benchmark out there.
And the reason is verification.
Unit test can pass, but the product is
probably still unusable and the front
end looks terrible.
Sweet marathon is the first benchmark to
use a computer use agent or CUA verifier
for these full stack tasks.
For the clone slack task, we have
deterministic unit tests to check the
API and the back end functionality.
But then a computer use agent uses the
browser like a human.
That's what you're seeing in this GIF.
The verifier isn't reading code or
calling an API directly.
It's driving the submitted slack clone
through the UI.
So it's logging in,
creating channels, posting messages,
reacting with emotes, and checking that
the app actually works with the rubric.
The big takeaway is that full stack
eval's are hard because correctness is
not just an API contract. It's whether
the user can actually complete the
product's intended workflow.
Sweet marathon has 20 project scale
tasks across four families.
There are library clones, full stack
product clones,
ML engineering, and algorithmic tasks.
And some of these tasks even use
external APIs. For example, we have a
post train task where the agent must
post train a language model using the
tinker API.
Expert contributors from the eval's
community propose the tasks and
reference solutions. And then we work
together to standardize them into
executable environments with the
multi-layer verifier suites.
Tasks all follow the harbor format.
A lot of my work was spent on the QA and
the hardening layer. So,
running the agent trials, inspecting the
failure modes,
patching the shortcuts, patching the
verifier, and then rerunning until the
tasks were both solvable,
but also hard to game.
This is the main leaderboard result. The
best configuration here is Claude Opus
4.8 with Claude Code, and it only
achieves a 26% resolution rate.
So, even with the strongest agent setup
we evaluated, it's only solving like one
in four tasks.
The important thing is that these aren't
shallow failures. The average trial used
31 million tokens, and the longest
rollout
consumed 877 million tokens. So, the
agents are exploring, editing, testing,
getting stuck, recovering, running for
hours.
So, the takeaway is that current agents
are very impressive, but end-to-end
project ownership ownership is still
very far from being solved.
This plot puts cost on the x-axis and
resolution rate on the y-axis.
So,
higher success rate for less money is
always better.
Claude Opus 4.8 is the top point. It
gets 26%, but it's also the most
expensive configurations, or one of
them.
Whereas GPT 4.5
with Codex is far cheaper and only gets
12%.
So, the model isn't just the full
picture. The agent scaffold makes a huge
difference
uh how the how it plans, uses tools,
um summarizes context, and decides on
when to test.
I won't get too deep into the cost
analysis here, but the paper has the
full details.
I wanted to show you what a full
marathon rollout actually looks like.
This is one I picked with GLM 5.2 on the
Next.js fight rewrite task.
So, there's over, you know, 356 million
tokens
uh over 9 hours and over 800 trajectory
steps and and tool actions.
So, for the top half, you can see the
the agent starts by exploring the repo
and the fixtures,
um
gets its first full test suite at zero
of
zero out of 325 test passing, and then
spends the next few hours pushing
through
routing, hydration,
uh server actions, middleware, and cache
behavior.
The bottom part of the chart shows the
work pattern over time. So, you can see
like lots of reading and searching
early, then huge waves of like editing,
building, testing, and debugging.
The key intuition is that
these are like long engineering loops.
They're not simple coding tasks.
Reward hacking is an arms race between
coding agents and our environment.
This is why strong verifiers are are
central to Sweep Marathon's task design
and not an afterthought.
This chart
has two levels of behavior. The lighter
bars
are the suspicious suspicious uh
shortcut behavior. So, things like
looking for solution files, messing with
data, messing with the configs.
Whereas the darker bar is like a clear
exploit that has actually gotten shipped
in the final submission.
And across the 1,400 rollouts,
um we found 12.8% had suspicious
shortcut behavior, and 9% had the clear
verifier bypass.
So, if these verifiers were weak, these
wouldn't just be
amusing failure cases, they would
actually delegitimize the benchmark.
And the important number is the zero.
Zero rollouts earned reward through an
exploit, because our defenses caught
them.
That should be the bar for long-horizon
evals.
This is my favorite concrete reward
hacking example.
The task is to build a C compiler in
Rust from scratch. The lexer, the
parser, semantic analysis,
codegen, the whole thing.
But Gemini found a much shorter
implementation strategy,
which is call GCC from inside
the Rust program.
So,
under a weak verifier, this task would
look almost solved, because the compiler
outputs match the reference behavior
behavior.
But obviously it's not a real compiler
in Rust.
The anti-cheat layers ca- uh catch this
by using S trace to find the forbidden
subprocesses
um called like GCC.
So, even though the partial scores look
high, the final reward is zero.
I have the full failure mode taxonomy in
the paper, um which I hope you guys will
check out.
If you remember one thing from this
video, it's that the future of SWE evals
is not just harder unit tests.
Once agents run for hours,
each task becomes a complex environment,
and agents not only trying to write
code, it's also navigating tools, tests,
your hidden assumptions, and the
verifier itself.
So, the two big takeaways are first,
long horizons we is still unsolved.
The best agents only at 26%. There's
plenty of headroom left.
Second, the big bottleneck is robust
verification.
At hour and day scale length tasks, we
need the multi-channel checks,
anti-cheat hardening,
product style validation.
The tasks, the code, the paper, the
logs, and the trajectories are all
public.
I've released 320 GB of trajectories
that are
especially important because they make
SWE-bench fully inspectable and
transparent.
I also want to thank all of my
collaborators on this project, all of
whom are listed here.
SWE-bench was very much a
community-driven effort across task
contributors, advisors, and paper
writing.
You can find everything at
swe-bench.org.
Thank you.